Blueprint interfaces are a way to efficiently communicate with various blueprints throughout
your project without having to load the entire blueprint into memory.
Now with our particular project, it's relatively small.
So this introduction to blueprint interfaces is to do just that and to introduce you to
blueprint interfaces because as your project grows in complexity, these are going to be
very, very important to your project's success.
So to create them, what we do is we come over to the content browser and we right click
and we look for the blueprint category and then we select our interface.
Inside the interface, it's going to look very familiar to a blueprint graph, but the big
difference is that it's going to say read only across the top here and we're only going
to be able to actually add inputs and outputs.
But for our case, what we're going to be doing is we're going to create a new blueprint interface
and we are going to add two inputs to it, a score and a time.
And that way we can more easily pass these values around to our interface and our car
and things like that.
So let's pop over to the editor and do this right now.
So I'm actually going to close this.
I'm going to hit control space and I'm going to navigate up to our content folder.
Right click.
We're going to go to blueprint and add a blueprint interface.
Now I like to call mine BPI for blueprint interface.
We're to call this think vehicle.
All right.
And then let's double click on it to open it up.
Now, once you have it open, we have a new function.
So we're going to right click on this and rename it to.
Hicked up objects.
And then what we're going to do is under our inputs, we're going to add one and two.
And we're going to call this one score.
We're going to call the other one time.
We also need to change these from Booleans to integer values.
So there we go.
Both sets integers.
And once we're done, we do need to compile and save.
What we need to do after that is we need to assign this blueprint interface
to the blueprint we wish to work with.
In our case, that's going to be the BP P sports car.
So what we're going to do is we're going to come back over here to the editor.
We're going to hit control space.
We're going to go look for our blueprints and then we're going to go sports car.
And there's our BP P sports car.
So that's the one that we want right there.
We double click on it to open it up.
And to add a interface, we come over to our class settings
and then under our interfaces, you can see we have this implemented interfaces.
Right now we have no interfaces.
So what we're going to do is we're going to go to add and then from the search,
we're going to type in BP I and that's going to bring everything down
a little bit easier for us to navigate.
And there's our BP I vehicle.
So we're going to click on that and compile and save.
Now, once we've done that, we are going to now create the following bit of code.
So what we're going to do is event picked up objects.
We're going to get the current score.
We're going to set the current score.
And then we're going to cast to our game mode to get the time remaining
and then set the time remaining.
And this is going to set up the logic for us to work with our pickups.
So to do this, what we're going to do here.
As we're going to come over to our BP sports car, we do need to add some variables.
So we're going to add one and two.
And this first one, we're going to right click and we're going to rename this one
to current score.
And actually, we don't need the second one right now.
We're actually just going to delete that.
So also need to change our current score to a integer and compile and save
so that we can use it.
So let's go ahead and just move somewhere off to the side here.
And what we're going to do now is we're going to look for our event picked up.
And there we go.
Event picked up objects.
And what are we going to do with this?
Well, for our, we need to get our current score.
So we're going to grab this and we're going to go get because we want to get
the current value of that.
So let's set up our score and then our time.
So we're going to take our score.
We're going to hit the plus sign here.
I'm going to go, you tell these operators add, we're going to add these two together.
All right.
So we want to take our current, our score from the pick up here, and then we want
to add that to our current score.
And then what we want to do is we want to take our current score.
We're going to bring this out again and we're going to go.
Set current score.
And what we're basically going to be doing is incrementing our score.
So as our score updates, we're going to take our current score.
We're going to add that to our score value that comes in here and then update
our current score again.
So basically we're going to iterate on our current score.
And we're going to do something similar with the time remaining.
So we're going to get game mode because I remember our time is set up inside of our game.
But we could have set the time up in here, but it's better to set the time up inside of the game mode.
And again, remember our game is very small.
This is just good practice for how things should be built inside of blueprints as your projects grow longer.
So what we're going to do here is from this return value, we are going to cast, not cast, but cast to BPGM Vehicle Basic.
There we go.
And we're also going to right click on this and convert this to a pure cast.
Now the difference is that basically pure cast is assuming that we know exactly what we're doing and the values that we are getting.
It's not going to involve any error checking.
So we're going to right click on this, convert to a pure cast.
And then what we're going to do here is we are going to go time and we are going to get the time remaining.
So there we go.
And then from our time here, what we're going to do is we're going to hit the plus sign.
So we have an ad operation.
And basically, again, we're going to do something very similar here.
I'm going to actually double click on this line to add what's known as a redirector to make this a little bit easier for us to see.
But we're going to take our from our game mode, we are going to get our time remaining and then we're going to take what the time remaining is.
And we are going to add that to the time that comes in from our pickup.
And then what we're going to do here is we are going to pull off of this set.
And we might be able to get this set time.
Nope.
What we're going to have to do is pull off of here.
So we're going to pull off of this and we're going to go a set time.
And there we go.
Set time remaining is the value that we are looking for.
And what we want to do here is we want to grab from this set and plug in like so.
And then we want to take the output of this addition and plug this in.
And I'm also going to double click on these lines to clear this up.
So for some reason, we have this extra node here.
So let's just move that out of the way.
So there we go.
That is what we're looking at.
Now, if you need a second or two to get caught up, we're going to pause right here now before we go into the next part.
Which is a score and time pickup.
So this is all we have for this part.
And when you are done, you should have something that looks like this.